we are in Buckingham Palace the very
heart of the British nation Sherlock
Holmes put your trousers on hey
youtubers it's Charlie in in case you
missed it they just cast a whole bunch
of people on Game of Thrones Season 4
that's right right around comic-con they
just started making announcements and we
have four new people on Game of Thrones
right now it would have been five but I
think they lost my letter asking for a
spot in the cast this season so
including the red Viper which was cast a
while ago we now have the mag nurofen
mace Tyrell one of the sand snakes and
one of the Greyjoy uncles that's right
there's even a doctor who person in
there who did the casting dragon gobble
up well first there's indira varma I
loved her on seasons one and two of
Luther so in case you haven't seen that
show check it out on Netflix it also has
a dress elba who basically headlines the
show who do you think he would play on
Game of Thrones probably someone really
badass there's mace Tyrell he's being
played by Roger Ashton Griffiths you
might not recognize them but here's a
picture he's been a really awesome
British character actor for a long time
so I think he'll provide a nice blend of
aristocracy and comedy then there's a
wildling Joseph gat he's actually this
really menacing looking guy as you can
see here I don't know how big his role
is gonna be on the show this year
because they gave a lot of his parts
from season 3 to the Lord of bones so
we'll see later as the season goes on
and then there's our Doctor Who actor
Mark Gatiss he is actually going to be
in a mall gum of several of the Greyjoy
uncles I'll talk more about that in a
second but how awesome is it that we
have a Sherlock and Doctor Who
connection on Game of Thrones now I mean
that's just like fandom nirvana right
there obviously i'm most excited about
the mark gatiss casting if you haven't
watched him on Sherlock he basically
plays Mycroft Sherlock's older brother
and although the Greyjoy's are really
serious and I think obviously the
Mycroft character kind of does that
really well obviously the Greyjoy's are
just completely bonkers so I think that
Mark Gatiss is gonna have a lot of fun
with this I'm actually guessing that the
Greyjoy he'll be playing will be victory
on and I'll explain why but I have to
talk about it with a few spoilers so in
case you don't want to hear just turn
the volume down for a second
okay so we already know that they're
going to compress those three Greyjoy
uncle characters into one character just
so they don't have to cast two extra
people so obviously that's where Mark
Gatiss comes in he actually said he'll
be speaking with an Irish accent which
kind of hints at the Greyjoy's just
based on the region that they're in we
can also guess in season three that
because they're compressing these
characters we won't see the Kingsmoot
which means that we not really sure what
Victorians going to be doing remember
he's the Lord Commander of their fleet
so he basically has all the ships and if
you remember at the end of season three
Asha sailed to save Theon from Ramsay
snow it's my guess that she's going to
be intercepted by Stannis on his way to
the wall and Victarion will have to
rescue her honestly I could go down some
of the way and we don't know when
Stannis is going to arrive at the wall
and we don't know what Ash's storyline
is going to be obviously she's probably
still going to be captured by Stannis's
fleet but we don't know when that's
going to happen or what episode it's
going to come in so let me know what you
think volume back up for those of you
who turned the volume down because you
didn't want to hear spoilers just to
summarize Mark Gatiss is awesome and you
need to watch sherlock right now I'll
actually be doing a big update for
Sherlock season 3 in a couple days be
sure to subscribe to get it I'm going to
VidCon on Thursday though so i'll do
that video after i get back and if you
are going to VidCon be sure to give me
high five I'll give you a high five
right back would that be funny if I just
left my hand right there I'll just walk
around like this they'll be crazy also
I'm gonna be down in Anaheim again in
two weeks for Disney's d23 they'll be
doing all kinds of great Star Wars and
Marvel stuff there if you remember they
didn't bring Star Wars to comic-con
because they were saving it for d23 so
i'll be posting some videos from that to
be sure to subscribe to get all that too
in the meantime thank you guys so much
you are so amazing I never thought that
I would get to fifteen thousand
subscribers so fast thank you so much
for the support you guys are all awesome
while you're thinking up awesome
questions to ask me be sure to click
here and watch my review of the very
first episode of Joss Whedon's agents of
shield or you can click here to learn
about when they're gonna announce the
brand new doctor who it's coming up
really soon so get excited thank you so
much you guys are awesome high fives
you